PROFESSOR: So here is
of something funny.
You might say, OK,
what is simpler?
A theory that is linear or
a theory that is not linear?
And the answer, of course, a
linear theory is much simpler.
General-- Maxwell's
equations are linear.
Einstein's theory of
relativity is very nonlinear,
very complicated.
How about classical mechanics?
Is classical mechanics
linear or nonlinear?
What do we think?
Can't hear anyone.
Linear, OK.
You may think it's linear
because it's supposed
to be simple, but it's not.
It's actually is very nonlinear.
Newton could solve
the two body problem
but he couldn't solve
the three body problem.
Already with three bodies, you
cannot superpose solutions that
you get with two bodies.
It's extraordinarily
complicated,
classical mechanics.
Let me show you.
If you have motion in
one dimension, in 1D,
you have the equation of
motion, motion in one dimension,
and there are potential V of
x, that this time independent--
a particle moving
in one dimension x
with under the influence
of a potential, V of x.
The second-- the dynamical
variable is x of t.
The dynamical variable.
And the equation of motion is--
so let me explain this.
This is force equal
mass times acceleration.
This is mass, this
is acceleration,
the second derivative
of the position,
and V force is minus the
derivative of the potential
evaluated at the position.
You know, derivatives
of potentials--
if you think of a potential,
the derivative of the potential
is here positive, and you
know if you have a mass
here, it tends to
go to the left,
so the force is on the
left, so it's minus.
So V prime is the derivative of
V with respect to its argument.
And the problem is that while
this, taking derivatives,
is a linear operation.
If you take two derivatives
of a sum of things,
you take two
derivatives of the first
plus two derivatives
of the second.
But yes, its-- this
side is linear,
but this side may not be linear.
Because a potential
can be arbitrary.
And that the
reverse-- so suppose
the potential is cubic in x.
V of x goes like x cubed.
Then the derivative of
V goes like x squared,
and x squared is not
a linear function.
So this, Newton's equation,
is not a linear equation.
And therefore, it's
complicated to solve.
Very complicated to solve.
So finally, we can get to
our case, quantum mechanics.
So in quantum mechanics,
what do we have?
Quantum mechanics is linear.
First, you need an equation,
and whose equation is it?
Schrodinger's equation, 1925.
He writes an equation for
the dynamical variable,
and the dynamical
variable is something
called the wave function.
This wave function
can depend on t--
depends on time-- and it may
depend on other things as well.
And he describes the dynamics
of the quantum system
as it evolved in time.
There is the wave function,
and you have an equation
for this wave function.
And what is the equation
for this wave function?
It's a universal
equation-- i hbar
partial derivative with
respect to time of psi
is equal to H hat of psi, where
H hat is called the Hamiltonian
and it's a linear operator.
That's why I had to
explain a little bit what
the linear operator is.
This is the general structure
of the Schrodinger equation--
time derivative and
the linear operator.
So if you wish to write the
Schrodinger equation as an L
psi equals 0, then L psi would
be defined i hbar del/del
t of psi minus H hat psi.
Then this is the
Schrodinger equation.
This equation here is
Schrodinger's equation.
And as you can see,
it's a linear equation.
You can check it, check
that L is a linear operator.
Therefore, it is naturally
linear, you can see,
because you do it differently,
because the derivative
with respect to time
is a linear operation.
If you have the ddt of a
number of times a function,
the number goes out, you
differentiate the function.
ddt of the sum of two functions,
you differentiate the first,
you differentiate.
So this is linear and
H we said is linear,
so L is going to be linear
and the Schrodinger equation
is going to be a
linear equation,
and therefore, you're going
to have the great advantage
that any time you find
solutions, you can scale them,
you can add them, you can put
them together, combine them
in superpositions, and
find new solutions.
So in that sense,
it's remarkable
that quantum
mechanics is simpler
than classical mechanics.
And in fact, you will see
throughout this semester
how the mathematics and
the things that we do
are simpler in
quantum mechanics,
or more elegant, more
beautiful, more coherent,
it's simpler and very nice.
OK, i is the square root of
minus 1, is the imaginary unit,
and that's what we're
going to talk next
on the necessity
of complex numbers.
hbar, yes, it's a number.
It shows up in quantum
mechanics early on.
It it's called Planck's
constant and it
began when Planck tried to
fit the black value spectrum
and he found the need to
put a constant in there,
and then later, Einstein figured
out that it was very relevant,
so yes, it's a number.
For any physical
system that you have,
you will have a wave
function and you
will have a Hamiltonian,
and the Hamiltonian
is for you to invent
or for you to discover.
So if you have a particle
moving on a line,
the wave function will
depend on time and on x.
If you have a particle
moving in three dimensions,
it will depend on x vector.
It may depend on
other things as well
or it maybe, like, one particle
has several wave functions
and that happens when you
have a particle with spin.
So in general, always
time, sometimes position,
there may be cases where it
doesn't depend on position.
You think of an electron at some
point in space and it's fixed--
you lock it there and
you want understand
the physics of that
electron locked into place,
and then position
is not relevant.
So what it does with
its spin is relevant
and then you may need more
than one wave function-- what
is one describing
the spin up and one
describing the spin down?
So it was funny that
Schrodinger wrote this equation
and when asked, so what
is the wave function?
He said, I don't know.
No physical interpretation
for the wave function
was obvious for the people that
invented quantum mechanics.
It took a few months
until Max Born said
it has to do with
probabilities, and that's
what we're going to get next.
So our next point is the
necessity of complex numbers
in quantum mechanics.